qu'est-ce qu'il y a de beau là dedans
il remonte tout un tas de merde le genre
que tu adores
c'était une fille et il y aura pas
d'enquête
on pense avoir trouvé des affaires qui
vous appartiennent je dois retrouver la
mère de cet enfant et vous allez me dire
je cherche une fille en particulier
c'est à propos du bébé elle est réservée
à des clients particuliers
je peux t'aider à savoir ce qui est
arrivé à ta fille vous êtes qui et vous
moi tout ce que je voulais c'est que ma
fille est une vie normale
je peux pas te cacher ici éternellement
il me retrouveront toute façon c'est
juste une question de temps
bonjour messieurs on m'a dit qu'ici je
pouvais récupérer ce que j'avais égaré